we move around sites much like a
photographer would taking pictures from
many locations but with a photographer
you have a single frame
by using our technology now each of
those pixels actually has a 3d location
xyz coordinates and we have now brought
that photograph to life in three
dimensions
my name is scott lee and i'm the
director of operations for sciarc we
have to move the scanner
all around the site in order to capture
every nook and cranny sciarc's mission
is to accurately capture archive and
share the world's cultural heritage what
makes the data really unique as you can
see we can look at it from every angle
so we can just pop literally go through
a window and let's check out the
interior of the chapel we're documenting
the physical evidence of the people came
before us and we're documented for the
people that come after us
sites in general face numerous threats
today whether it's environmental or the
intentional destruction of heritage
especially in the middle east
these sites are being destroyed faster
than they can be physically preserved
part of this initiative is to digitally
document them so we have a record for
humanity
and possible reconstruction in the
future
cyric has done over 200 projects on all
seven continents from mount rushmore in
the united states to chichen itza in
mexico
to the tower of london in europe
even the sydney opera house in australia
as we move around these sites we capture
billions and billions of points and we
collect you know tons of data
this is the data set we captured in
mexico city this is templo mayor what
makes the site really unique is
it was recently discovered actually in
the 70s which for archaeology is very
recent if you can't come to temple mayor
in mexico city we'll pop on your
computer and you can virtually access
this
we are walking on the archaeology
it's very fragile you need to be careful
where you step where you put your
machines how you document documenting
these sites and storing them for future
generations is an important endeavor
i come to work every day knowing i'm
doing something good for humanity
because without knowing our past we
won't know our future
you